What's good a family?
Small business heroes know threats can come from anywhere.
This is the story of a little business that's weathered a lot.
From natural disasters, to health scares and lockdowns,...
...there's a lot out there that can freeze a business.
Meet the Vourderis family, owners of Deno's Wonder Wheel.
It's a family business they've run for decades.
When the challenges arose, putting their future very much in jeopardy,...
...they looked for inspiration from the past.
Grandpa Denos came to this country with the courage to build an empire,...
...promising his wife the biggest ring in the world.
That ring turned out to be a New York City landmark.
Still, everything in the atmosphere conspired to crush their dream.
The odds were stacking up against,...